a well-crafted plot twist can take a
movie from good to great in fact some
movies are regarded as classics
specifically because of twists that
completely recontextualize the story but
sending the narrative in an unexpected
direction sometimes just ends up making
a film worse as great as it feels to be
surprised by an excellent plot twist
these movies would have been better off
without them as always beware the
spoilers ahead remember me there's
nothing wrong with the simple romance
movie and as far as that element goes
remember me isn't too bad
it's Leeds Robert Pattinson and Emilie
de Ravin are solid enough in their roles
and boasts a nice chemistry and while it
may veer into cliche the film still
certainly has its charms but all of that
goes completely and inexplicably down
the drain in the movies final moments
the film has become infamous for its
final act which reveals that the entire
story has been leading up to Robert
Pattinson 's character being in the
World Trade Center on September 11 it's
a subject matter that remember me
bungles badly taking a horrific tragedy
and using it as cheap emotional
manipulation
I mean why aren't you aside from being
deeply insensitive it's also a case of
blown potential as the romantic drama is
just fine without resorting to the
careless and contrived finale the
village the biggest problem with the
village is that its twists turns into a
much worse movie writer director M night
Shyamalan last act plot twists helped
launch his career but they ended up
becoming notorious to the point of
parody after this one the horror film
appears to Center on a small
nineteenth-century village which has
been surrounded by mysterious monsters
but it's actually revealed that the
creatures don't exist they're just the
town elders in costume trying to scare
people into staying put in their safe
community that's all well and good
enough until the second twist arrives to
reveal the film actually takes place in
the modern day and the village elders
created these monsters to keep their
people protected from the woes of the
outside world with just the first twist
in place the movie might work as a solid
social commentary but the second drug
pool makes the movie needlessly
convoluted
Specter given the film's title it's not
surprising that Specter centers on the
villainous organization headed up by
Ernst Blofeld one of double-oh-seven s
greatest villains or that Christoph
Waltz was brought in to portray the
criminal mastermind
despite some slack attempts at secrecy
so thank you cool but instead of simply
rebooting the iconic villain waltzes
character is also eventually revealed to
be bonds adopted brother making a
surprise return after faking his own
death the twist is completely
superfluous the original Blofeld is a
force of pure evil and he doesn't need
to be tied to bond in any way to be
effective the revelation that bond has a
secret brother who ended up
orchestrating the events in the previous
Daniel Craig led Bond films strains all
credibility for his run in the franchise
James the author of all the pain but
simply it's a twist that twists too hard
savages Oliver Stone's film adaptation
of savages initially seems to end like
the book with the demise of basically
every character providing a sort of
closure it also fits in well with the
way the storytellers want viewers to see
the three main characters they're too
wild for this world and it only makes
sense for them to go out in a blaze of
glory
unfortunately stone tacks on a twist
wherein the ending is revealed to be an
elaborate fantasy playing out in the
head of one character instead the bad
guys get arrested and the good guys get
out clean riding off into the sunset
this disjointed happy ending isn't just
a cheap it feels like a painfully safe
move high tension when crafting a good
plot twist it's incredibly important to
consider whether it appends the
plausibility of the story unfortunately
for Alexandre Aja's high tension its
Hail Mary of a twist ending in which the
killer is revealed to be a dissociative
identity of the protagonist since
plausibility down the drain the film up
until that point is a pretty
straightforward slasher that stands out
for its artful gore so why the needless
twist shots filmed from the villains
point of view make little sense after
the twist and the film's opening is even
more confusing when it's watched while
knowing who the killer turns out to be
secret window
speaking of misuse of dissociative
identity disorder secret window also
stumbles in this presentation of the
illness it should be a slam dunk of a
movie based on a Stephen King short
story it's about a writer who retreats
to a cabin in the woods to craft his
next book only to be confronted by a
deranged stranger named shooter who
claims he is plagiarized one of his
works you stole my story tensions
between the two escalate and eventually
turn to violence the twist is that
shooter doesn't exist and is instead a
result of our leads mental and wellness
which conveniently has never manifested
in the movie until this moment
sometimes this twist works like with
Fight Club and primal fear but in secret
window it comes off as uninspired which
is ironic considering how much we hear
about stories needing to stick the
landing throughout the only thing that
matters is the ending scream 3 the first
film in the scream franchise features a
twist that is revelatory for the horror
genre there are two culprits behind the
film's slaughter spree not just one
surprise Sydney the twist is so good
that it's repeated in the sequel scream
2 and mostly still works for the third
film though the filmmakers go with a new
twist and it ends up being just plain
dumb part of the reason the first two
films in the franchise enjoy such
reverence is that they function as
critiques of the genre they're
self-aware and skewer the typical tropes
that had started the bored audiences
the problem with scream 3 is needlessly
complicated reveal is that it resembles
something from the film's the franchise
itself satirizes the revelation that the
baddie in this film is screen
protagonist Sydney's secret half-brother
and that he has effectively orchestrated
the events of the entire series is
completely unbelievable it's a jump the
shark moment and a franchise that scoffs
at cliche and closes out the original
series with a whimper instead of well a
scream but hey credit the stew for
trying to tie everything together and
save the story again if you find
yourself dealing with an unexpected
backstory and a preponderance of
exposition then the sequel rules
not apply thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you love to